le parti conservateur et le bloc
québécois sont les deuxième et troisième
parties à présenter leurs cadres
financiers après les libéraux
l'économiste serge coulombe de
l'université d'ottawa est avec nous pour
en parler ce soir bonsoir
bonsoir on table donc sur un retour à
l'équilibré en sept ans chez les
conservateurs vous avez jeté un oeil
donc sur ce plan qui a été présenté
aujourd'hui est ce que ce plan est
crédible
donc c'est toujours difficile de
considérer un plan budgétaire pour
quatre ans c'est encore plus difficile
pour certains est encore plus difficile
pour dix ans il ya énormément plus
d'incertitudes puisque la période
s'allonge donc que ce dépôt vraiment
crédible c'est surtout que ça ça montre
une intention une détention d'un retour
à l'équilibré budgétaire dans l'avenir
et on sait comment chez des
conservateurs c'est un récital outil qui
a été important avec stephen harper qui
a utilisé le retour à l'équilibré
budgétaire pour diminuer la taille du
gouvernement donc c'est de la politique
économique pour satisfaire les
conservateurs mais le retour n'est pas
pressé c'est pas il ya aucun
empressement le déficit demeure élevé
encore pour au moins 2 années - et donc
il se recentre vous savez les deux
autres partis majeurs au canada sont
beaucoup plus à gauche au niveau de
l'orientation économique ou est ce que
c'est la dépense qui qui prime alors lui
il se sent tout en gardant la notion de
liquide hybride quand on dit pas de
compression des économies en annulant un
programme de garderies pas vraiment on
limite les nouvelles dépenses et on
prévoit que les mesures du clan vont
même générer des revenus est ce que tout
ça tient la route pour vous dans
laquelle ce n'est pas la route c'est que
toutes les recettes qu'on sa batterie
soit faire augmenter la croissance de
réelle du pib canadien d'un point 5 % à
3 % par année ça ça se voit poche et les
pays qui ont atteint hier un rythme de
développement comme les pays du g7 on
l'a vu des mesures agressives de
recherche et de développement et de
relance structurelle de l'économie en
corée à taiwan et ces pays étaient en
rade page donc il n'ya pas de recette
magique mais heureusement monsieur
étudiants les conservateurs n'ont pas
intégré les résultats de la recette
magique dans l'eure dans leur budget ils
ont ils ont gardé les mêmes prévisions
que le directeur parlementaire du budget
comme fille il était peut-être même pas
non plus certain de pouvoir stimuler
cette économie les conservateurs
réduisent font passer de 6 milliards à
660 millions de dollars le transfert au
québec pour les garderies parce qu'on
veut annuler complètement ce programme
national qui a été annoncé par monsieur
trudeau tout juste avant les élections
est ce que pour vous c'est dans ce plan
là l'économie la plus importante du plan
conservateur
l'économie pour la cc pour l'ensemble
des provinces également le fédéral
promettait de participer au lancement
d'un système de garderie comme au québec
dans les autres provinces donc oui c'est
une c'est une
c'est une des
belles économies projetées un des plus
important à mon avis c'est probablement
la plus importante et c'est évident que
ce sera pas populaire au québec parce
que le québec paient déjà
avec de l'argent qui est des poids pour
avoir le régime de garde mais dans les
autres provinces on ne payait pas déjà
donc le calcul sera pas de même ces
faits clairement une mesure qui risque
d'aller chercher certains votes chez
ceux qui ne sont pas en faveur des
garderies publiques dans les autres
provinces
mais en perdre de l'autre côté pour ceux
qui veulent un système à la québécoise
concret mais ok c'est évident ça
implique un transfert en santé on avait
10 6% par année compte tenu que la
formule actuelle prévoit déjà à peu près
6 % par année compte tenu que la
croissance du pib nominal est forte là
on touche les 6% dont on voit dans le
cadre financier que les sommes
supplémentaires ne seront pas très
grande est ce que ça peut répondre quand
même aux attentes des provinces de oui
le la croissance de 6% par année c'était
une demande historique des provinces
note l'igas et depuis qu avant dans
l'arrivée de monsieur trudeau les
transferts en santé ont augmenté à un
rythme de 6 % par année et depuis 2016
dans une année a pas d'avis de monsieur
trudeau ils ont augmenté uniquement deux
tours pour 1 6% par année donc il faut
comparer sa c2 aller jusqu'en 2021 donc
il faut comparer le style pour sa part
rapport aux trois autres 3.6 ce qui
impliquerait une donc une augmentation
d'environ 2 points 4 % par année et on
pourrait se diriger
bon an mal an vers la cible de faire
passer des transferts fédéraux de santé
de 22 à 35 % d'ici vite ou le ventre
peut-être et donc c'est solide et parce
que 6 % c'est un peu plus que la
croissance nominale du pib moyen au
canada au cours des vingt dernières
années et c'est à peu près le taux de
croissance des dépenses en santé des
provinces également mais comme on a eu
moins que si c'est pour ça depuis 2005
c'est clair que ça prendrait une
certaine forme de rattrapage parfois on
s'arrête si serge coulombe on va revenir
dans notre ca sur le bloc québécois
également merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
oh